oh those are some pretty hot moves out
there oh you know what
now to make this hotter well let's take
your boots off
no stupid sexy former who are you I'm a
simple girl I see Eugene I click click
good morning I'm just waking up in this
giant king bed next to some mountains
easy easy
contrast oh yeah we got three twin bed
how cute is three twin bed three twin
beds actually I should call triplet beds
Oh Jojo so sour time look who's awake
oh yeah
what are you teens doing Hey Eugenie's
also not wearing much clothes yes so
bright beautiful day right over here I'm
here with Zach Cornbelt he just woke up
in Mammoth California Zach what's on
your mind and my tote this store I'm
sleepy very funny we are gonna go ski ah
who's ready to ski
that what we're doing with your birthday
you know I never went skiing before here
it's very cool here people have fun
doing it so we just found out that
there's no picking her trail open today
it's over yeah like he's never skied
before I don't I don't think we should
tell him because if we tell him he's not
gonna come and I am not wearing any
pants
whose ex birthday the other day he got a
pecan pie and he saved one piece for
himself
I don't want to be worried about
finishing the pipe so let's take a fire
too
oh uh we're all waiting on Zach it's
usually the case right yeah I hate it
when we're running behind looks like we
better catch up oh you can't tell turn
it that way there it started oh no no it
looks like no today yeah Zach what's
going on you got some got some shorts
over there we got some boots outside
sorry eat your pie Zach better go and do
the mountain
yeah Zach come on see the bunch I love
skiing good this breathe and this black
later we all basically making the same
amount of money I was here when I was a
kid I don't have to be a high energy ski
when I was kid have been shot since I
was kid I guess it's like riding a bike
got it locked in really I saw your so
await Wow
maybe that's why Casey nice that way so
much yeah oh my God look at this I my
European cuz this breakfast dispenser
mom told Keith you're probably gonna be
a better skier Zach today I probably
will be you know why athleticism
natural-born talent skill the ability to
put most of a banana in my mouth hey you
know look at you you're so different
looking I have no product in my hair but
whoop nobody makes a big deal about Zach
Oh
I want to size you to that you look tiny
you look today's special guest in the
trial log writer what a guy you guys on
the road I came out there at 6:00 and
there was just as Paris in the poor you
know he's kind of looked at us and when
I walked away
it was a cute yeah super cute oh nice
shot Keith thank you so much this your
first time to any sort of ski lodge
right I never been to a ski world
apparently I'm nervous skiing before
you'll be great at it Keith maybe all it
takes is coordination you're about to be
a poor tree come on out Zach you wacky
but and I nailed it
the mammoth main lodge you guys pretty
much ready you want to like get on
rental stuff for ya first of all let's
talk about that shirt okay crazy joke
yeah it's a little hot Friday so I
figured you know we're getting on the
slopes in July what is this I don't know
it's sovereign it has been a dream of
mine to ski in short sleeves my entire
life we always try to stay open as late
as we can usually on average there's
like till July 4th this is like our
second longest season we've ever had
we're closing officially next Sunday
which yeah
I ran to a wall who are you guys
you'll see bones you'll go on any vessel
Keith never skied before
yeah you have any advice for now all
right so right now at this point in
season because it's like almost August
dad there's nobody slopes so you're
going straight to intermediate no I'm
not intermediate at all well it's our
only choice real talk what is let's see
the potential for injury and
hospitalization have you ever gotten
injured yes well going to rocks you just
can't stop yourself because but you'll
break your wrist if you try to support
yourself going down right on your face
those kids are they're having a great
time yeah it's like it's winter and
they're on a bunny slopes we have to
change into appropriate ski appropriate
ski attire we just met you but we're
gonna take our pants off that Joe cool
kids on a ski slope
they're like skiing like funny costumes
they've like cool helmets be that a
parrot chicken yes there's no receiving
button oh are you sure you're okay I'm
on circumcise so you actually do pose a
threat to me right now no dicks out for
this giraffe Oh apparently you can
sunburn your eyeballs which is that is
the most terrifying because I do
election yeah you don't wanna go snow
blind
that's a tomato
[Applause]
so everyone's got the same skis except
have a burger for me so cute they are
look back in smile Keith okay so we're
gonna go off the gondola cuz we have to
go to right here cuz all the dirt
someone else mountain biking yeah
normally even this would be scary this
isn't as bad I've been on these kind of
cable cars let's see this a chair well
we're about to go on the church Aaron's
gonna scare me because we can put a par
down yeah I would like that that's the
kind of chair left where you kind of
have to ski off of it yes yeah then
we're gonna get up to where it's snow
then we're gonna go up Jer three and
we're gonna go off the back is more of a
comfort in the winter because you're
like oh that plush snow that'll catch my
fall they're like oh right let's rock
steep is between our two ski instructors
here
oh god this is everything I hate is it
yeah but cuz there's no barrier you're
going like this focus on where we're
going up there okay cool I've never ski
in the summer he gets blood yeah
foreshadowing put his bar down he said
he didn't want it but I want to be a big
boy here we go
say where these blues are and that takes
us down back saddlebow saddle ball
exactly this is fun
yeah it's like riding a horse oh he
doesn't like or spit oh no watch at the
baby giraffe takes his first steps no no
no no no no no no no okay you're doing
good beautiful majestic I'm not doing
great Lockwood but eventually he gets a
slide to the side around yeah good job
Kate what a nightmare this is awful
everything's hard at first when you
first try that's really there are
several things you can do without any
fail with the first time watching TV
eatin food see you later Kate this is a
great area to practice so anytime you
wanna stop like this Pizza
and then stop yourself hey they're like
a model I don't feel like now so far I'm
not enjoying this go up higher then
you'll get some speed speed is relative
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go a little bit to the right
hey get farther away from him and hey he
kind of kind of gotta use this girl
please
alright yeah there he goes there he goes
but I found a way down quick haha just
like the majestic giraffe
I really just hated yeah yeah it's
really bumming me out that Keith is not
liking skiing we're something I could do
it's okay to take a rest I'll take a
little rest you know I'm not wearing any
pants like fried chicken at the end of
the rainbow there you go
oh so good you did that you did the turn
you had a nice control all right that's
what about
[Music]
I came out here now we need to do this
what's your skill level but I was able
to turn once you know one one minor
success and a sea of failures or a
mountain of failure maybe that's a
better metaphor alright Keith did an
amazing job but he's decided to conquer
it for a day then it's time to ramp it
up ramp it up
[Applause]
alright guys with that are out skiing
I'm in a little log vlogging feel like
we should really own the root word of
vlog which is log so naughty
well speedo sign baby let's do that me
some hardwood over here with this log
[Music]
[Music]
bark is worse than its bite Ltd Laoag
transmitted disease over here fungus is
just somebody having fun the guy named
Gus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what a mistake we've made Wow ah but
that's why you wear helmets it's also
why you normally wear clothes crazy log
world out here
Wow is a lot to enjoy the ski ski
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my girls I'm ready here and the coast
we we finish skiing but where are we in
this key store requiring the ski store
for sex buying a shirt why really late
for Zack I love this shirt I'm gonna
wear this I'm gonna spill its balsamic
as soon as I can I need alcohol
thanks so much it's like when can you
have a fresh ski but also then the
Summer Sun I think it's about time we
let you be the experts today so I'm not
a beginner at this is an intermediate vo
though if you are a beginning eater I
would not jump straight into this is
dangerous it's a lot we made skiing look
sexy
we're about to make it food keep it sexy
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
I'm writing here and well this is our
second blog we hope you enjoyed it it
was a blog until next time try Tubbs the
nerdiest dinosaur
[Music]
[Music]
we just realized that we think that this
is technically gonna be our hundredth
release as the try guys respected skiing
in speedos very fitting well thanks for
watching all of our videos Oh